le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous présente lien social le conseil
départemental aux côtés des réunionnais
il s'avère que le bois de goyavier est
une véritable peste végétale que le
conseil départemental en tant que
propriétaire de 80% des forêts doit
enlever pour laisser respirer les
nombreuses plantes endémiques de ce bois
qui est coupée chaque jour en forêt est
née une histoire incroyable qui a donné
lieu à une merveilleuse aventure humaine
sociale et économique
la filière bois de goyavier des objets
du mobilier urbain mais aussi un mode
d'hébergement insolite d'une expérience
inoubliable au coeur de la nature ont vu
le jour pour une clientèle toujours plus
exigeante en devenant une vitrine
extraordinaire du savoir faire
réunionnais comment est née cette
filière
quels en sont les résultats on en parle
tout de suite d'un lien social
la filière bois de goyavier c'est
l'histoire d'une rencontre entre la
présidente du conseil départemental
nassimah dindar est un homme jean
françois waroux artisans de la plaine
des cafres immédiatement séduite par les
réalisations de ces objets en bambou et
en bois de goyavier la présidente prend
conscience du potentiel de développement
économique et d'insertion pour les
jeunes et c'est en 2011 que la
structuration de la filière voit le jour
l'objectif du conseil départemental est
alors de contribuer au renouveau de
l'artisanat au développement de
techniques innovantes à la valorisation
de la créativité et des compétences un
véritable parcours entre le savoir être
et le savoir faire se met en route les
atouts de ce bois pays devienne un
élément déco aménagements en valorisant
le patrimoine du mobilier urbain
poubelles ben kiosque en forêt abribus
puis du mobilier d'intérieur chaises
tables tabouret et du mobilier de
décoration sortent chaque jour des
ateliers de la filière bois de goyavier
en 2013 l'ouverture d'un showroom à
l'espace raid l'est permettent aux
touristes et aux réunionnais d'acquérir
ces réalisations est une nouvelle étape
arrive en 2015 avec la création d'un
nouveau mode d'hébergement avec deux
cabanes insolites et dormir dans un fil
à eau au bord de l'eau n'est désormais
plus un rêve c'est donc depuis le début
que jean-françois hoarau amène toutes
ses compétences pour toutes ces
réalisations
les ateliers de la filière bois de
goyavier on formait depuis 2011 plus de
200 personnes et sur l'année 2015 80
personnes ont bénéficié du parcours
d'insertion
ce projet n'est
suite à toutes les démarches qu'on a mis
depuis
et depuis 2011 la naissance de la
filière au chaudron à saint denis
on a un gros atelier qui est produit
autour de l'habitat et dans la bêta on
va partir sur les distances et leur
cuisine en passant par les accessoires
de jardin les chats panther et
ce que vous voyez derrière moi une
victime dans l'hébergement dans le ce
qui représente une autre façon de voir
avec
des produits transformés s'ils viennent
de l'ul de notre île
on a intégré
le minéral le passage de notre île le
goyavier bien sûr mais aussi aux autres
produits de construction tels que le
cryptomérias pour la superstructure des
habitacles que vous voyez derrière le
but de ces cabanes 1 ct de dans
l'écotourisme devoir dormir autrement
l'innovation la danse était construire
cette ces cabanes mais avec un public en
insertion et c'est la vocation de la
filière qu'on a au sein du département
je regarde le bois de goyavier de la
forêt équipe est envahissante passés par
nos ateliers où on le fait bouillir et
on le redressement le cintre selon le
travail qu'on doit on doit réaliser
et voilà les éléments sont produits en
atelier à le but
c'est que les gens arrivent chez nous
soit par un contrat aidé contrat
d'avenir ou autre contrat ils ont des
compétences certes mais cette compétence
liés aux matériaux bois qu'on a on a su
mettre en place au sein du département
leur est favorable
dans la suite de leur parcours
d'initiation dans le prendre au
personnel est tout content et fier pour
que cette filière dans la façon qu'elle
est en train de
s'inscrire dans ce désastre économique
de la réunion le conseil départemental
nous sommes chargés de couper une peste
végétale qui s'appelle le bois de
goyavier évident et de l'utiliser et de
le transformer en un objet fini dans des
meubles nous est venue mais avec le
double avantage celui d'employés des
jeunes et des moins jeunes au chômage en
contrat d'association qui ont été formés
par des artisans créole qui avait gardé
le savoir faire donc c'est la filière
bois de goyavier aujourd'hui le vvf de
saint gilles a été occupée et agrémenté
avec des produits mais les arrêts de bus
également des paniers que vous voyez sur
les routes départementales et ses agents
formés en constitue aujourd'hui une
entreprise unique
une coopérative et ils ont créé donc
leur propre emploi formé création de
l'emploi de leurs activités et donc du
développement et de la richesse pour
l'art et la réunion classé au patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité par l'unesco peut
être fier de sa nature et aussi de ces
sommes toujours plus inventifs
le conseil départemental acteur
incontournable du développement
touristique de l'île valoriser met en
exergue le recyclage pour une île plus
propre plus riche plus forte et pour
dire que la réunion est ambitieuse et à
de merveilleux atouts cette
extraordinaire aventure vient de partir
à l'export dans la boutique de l'antenne
de paris où les produits du travail de
jeunes réunionnais y sont proposés à la
vente de beaux projets sont en cours
pour l'avenir de notre île où un
développement dans le domaine du textile
est à l'étude et verra le jour très
prochainement le conseil départemental
de la réunion vous a présenté lien
social
le conseil départemental aux côtés des
réunionnais